when I'm wrestling I see the lights up
above
I just think of their figure mostly and
what I have to target
I hear them panting you're the coach
telling them like staying it
I like winning and feeling that you
dominant yeah I'm pretty quite tough
actually during matches awesome
max lamb Rustler Mars Pennsylvania 95
pounds 13 years old I used to be able to
see just out of my right eye I try to
remember my friends faces my parents and
families faces the way that he lost his
vision and the way that he embraced it
with the courage he wasn't downtrodden
he wasn't he just he just kind of
accepted it Max's first Braille teacher
when he was three he had said if you
treat him as if he has a disability then
he will be disabled I see light
perception which is light and darkness I
don't really see figures look I have a
guide dog his name is seal we've seen
the independent level of him go up he
will walk to the bus stop it's quite a
ways up there to the corner and uh Max
and seal go
seal does not get to watch me wrestle
because he's very protective he doesn't
want me to get hurt
Max has really only been wrestling for
about a year and a half so what he
laxative technique he mix it up and
strength for how slender he is he's like
a steel band
told my parents that I wanted to wrestle
in second grade I got my butt beat
pretty hard but that didn't stop me from
trying it again and now it's my passion
because that was the sport he could do
he could no longer do soccer you
couldn't do football that would be his
sport that he could do independently I
think my mom was a little worried about
me wrestling she doesn't want me to get
hurt watching max wrestle I'm scared I
just want his eyes to remain stable he's
being thrown around on the mat it's a
definitely a drive in life it teaches
you a lot of different things a lot of
different skills max Brussels are about
95 pound weight class
he's a very competitive kid has had very
good close matches with top-notch
quality kids it's very special to be
Max's friend you know very unique you
don't get to meet many kids like that
when I'm running with max he mostly just
stays by my sides fairly easy but when
we do stuff like rolls and somersaults
and stuff like that I'll try to watch
out for them because you have to be his
eyes I've seen some wrestlers take it
easy on Max and they end up regretting
it in the long run because they realize
he's not gonna take it easy on them I
want them to go 100% I just want them to
think like they're just raising another
kid he doesn't like people saying like
oh you need extra help because you're
blond he doesn't like that he doesn't
want extra help he just wants to be
normal
he really does have a unique
characteristic a bottom how much heart
and integrity he does happen within one
meeting with a doctor our world was
turned upside down I noticed his right
eye would go a little bit lazy at times
so Eric and Lisa came into the office
and as soon as I shined the light into
Max's eye I could see that he had a
white pupil a white pupil generally
means it's retinal blastoma or cancer in
the eye they looked into his eyes turned
the light back on and say
listen you have one very sick boy if the
cancer metastasizes out of the eye it
gets into the pineal gland it's almost
100% fatal by the age of five the first
thing that popped into both of our minds
was rather maybe going to live I don't
think people understand what he went
through at 11 months 12 months of age
they injected chemotherapy agents
directly into both eyes I know he didn't
understand what was going on at the time
but the the pain involved in that and
the discomfort he went through kids
tough as nails
I am a little nervous about the
tournament coming up because he's gonna
be a lot of good grass stores there I
think we'll do pretty good you know
there's a bunch of other kids here in
Pennsylvania that are really good but I
think max will go to hold his ground
rule with a blind wrestler is you always
have to be able to maintain contact and
so with Max he has to always be in
contact I can't imagine what it would be
like without wrestling with sight I mean
it's so different because you don't know
where other people legs are or arms
the limitations that matches going to
deal with with wrestling is a select set
of technique that he'll he really won't
be able to have a lot of exposure with
but the things that he has to his
benefit are he's going to continue to
gain natural feel and rely on his
physical instincts wrestling max was
pretty cool like first I thought I
should take it easy on but then he's
very strong you didn't even know he's
blind
2014 battery of the bird 95 pounder
max lamb
when we went to max and we said that
bleacher report wanted to do a story
about him his comment was well why most
people that can see they probably think
that I can't do myself that I can do I
think the future holds for max
everything and anything that he wants he
puts his mind to it and I think he can
achieve it I like to take my wrestling
talk college I want to go to get a
wrestling scholarship he will be his own
limitation you only get what you can
handle we would Bend we never broke and
it made our entire family stronger yeah
sometimes get upset that I lost my sight
because I definitely want my sight back
but I'm not just gonna sit around
complaining that I want it back when I
can do all this stuff